ton nom je me souviens qu'il est doux
mais seulement comme ceux d aimé que la
vie exil à son regard est pareil au
regard des statuts et pour savoir la
lointaine est calme et gravel inflexion
des voix chair qui se sont vu offrir un
poème de paul verlaine dans la rue non
la poésie n'est pas enfermé dans son
sérail elle c'est aller au contact des
habitants comme ce samedi au centre
commercial 17 mar à elancourt une
opération qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la 6e biennale de poésie je trouve ça
génial parce que comme j'aime beaucoup
de poésie
je trouve ça
enrichissant et
trés
trés des contractants si je ne lis pas
beaucoup de poésie mais c'est
c'est bien c'est une bonne initiative à
une initiative menée sur quatre sites
commerciaux de l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise dans le rôle des
clameurs de rue ce samedi la compagnie
compte en banque qui a déjà présenté un
spectacle au prisme pour attirer le
passant dans leurs filets de mots ces
poètes n'hésite pas à suivre le pas
pressé des habitants d'autres se
montrent meilleur public
ça attire les gens à la culture c'est
bien ce qu'ils font c'est vous avez
récupéré aussi des poèmes qu'on vous
abonner
j'ai les envoyer en petite chérie
prouver que la poésie quelque chose qui
est accessible à tout le monde elle
n'est pas faite par tous mais elle est
faite pour tous et combien de wenger le
jeune homme on aime la poésie oui parce
que je crois que ta poésie fait appel à
un intime et cette intime que chacun
peut le retrouver même sur l'espace
public le temps d'une écoute le temps
d'un partage avec un comédien qui dira
un texte et une carte postale avec
laquelle repartir à la maison
mais dois je les ai trempé dans l'amitié
des mains des enfants du quartier des
mains du monde entier
aux fins de la 6e biennale de poésie à
saint quentin en yvelines ce sera le 31
mars